this program is brought to you by Emory
University what's interesting about the
x-men is they take up a conversation
that actually started in its modern form
after World War Two and it started back
in the Nuremberg Nazi doctors trials as
they're called which were trials of ten
physicians and three Nazi administrators
for Hume experimentations they had done
of just the most horrific kind the
judges at that trial
we're so outraged not only by what they
heard that the Nazis did but actually as
the American witnesses came in and the
cross-examination brought out some of
the things that were happening in the
United States that were if not equally
terrible pretty bad
which is one of the ways that the
defense attorney tried to justify what
the Nazis had done the judges were so
appalled that they wrote the Nuremberg
code which was the first real code of
human experimentation that laid out in a
very clear way with a whole set of
standards what had to happen in order to
ever use a human being in medical
experimentation and included everything
from animal experimentation first to
some assurance of the expertise of the
investigators to full consent of the
subjects believe it or not even after
that it took another two decades before
those kinds of even more than two
decades before those kinds of standards
really began to be applied universally
at least in the developed world it took
that long also for the real breadth and
depth of the Nazi atrocities to become
known broadly widely across society
people knew about them but a lot of them
weren't talked about especially in the
fifties and early sixties and part of
that also was the movement of the 60s
things like disability rights movements
and feminism that began to talk about
empowering people to make those kinds of
decisions when all of those things came
together interestingly a lot of that
stuff was discussed in comic books
especially Marvel Comics which were much
more socially aware and then DC Comics
for example and talked about really
tough social issues in a way that
Superman and Batman didn't and so the
x-men became this fascinating discussion
of majority-minority relationships human
experimentation the coming genetic
sophistication and then as you move into
the 70s you have around 75 the Asilomar
meeting which was a meeting of
geneticists where they all got together
and they said well group of them got
together in Asilomar california and said
we're beginning to mess with a
biological technology genetic
technologies of immense power and great
possibility of causing harm so we need
to set up some guidelines voluntary
guidelines that everyone will use who
engages in genetics of various kinds to
make sure that we don't step over some
ethical boundaries so that conversation
was percolating through American society
and was reflected in groups like the ax
men
you
the preceding program is
be righted by Emory University